Democrats are in messaging mode right
now so they're going to fight
Republicans in the house on everything
we do because in the house is the only
place that Republicans have National
Power we don't have it in the Senate we
don't have it in the white house so
they're in 2024 presidential campaign
mode so Hakeem Jeffries the the minority
leader in the with the Democrats he
calls us extreme Mega Republicans every
single day AOC calls us fascist and
every other name that she can think of
although I I would say people should
really pay attention to AOC she's the
true fascist you see what fascism is is
it's that I call it the Unholy Union of
big corporations and big government and
they have completely aligned together
and it hurts the little people the
little people that she claims uh to
protect and support
foreign
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the congresswoman representing Georgia's
14th District congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor green welcome to the Reuben
report thank you it's good to be here I
am glad to have you I said to you right
before we started we've got some polls
up here that I thought maybe you could
do some pull-ups because you're always
you're always doing exercise on the
capitol should we start that way with a
couple pull-ups or maybe we'll finish
that we can finish that way we'll finish
that way so you know it's funny I've
never sat down with you before and I'm
sitting down with probably about 15 or
20 Congress people and Senators Etc and
people think of you as very
controversial and so I was like all
right I really want to figure out what
is what is truly like the position you
hold that is the most controversial
and I really couldn't come up with that
much so maybe we start there what do you
make of that notion well it seems to be
in Washington DC if you come in very
convicted in your beliefs and really
represent your district and the beliefs
that your District told you know things
like secure borders a strong economy
freedom of speech protecting our Second
Amendment uh saying no more Foreign Wars
let's focus on America and America first
um being Unapologetic about being
pro-life wanting to protect children
that seem to be under attack from these
gender lives things like that Washington
DC and the mainstream media labels
extreme but actually in real America you
know Northwest Georgia where I come from
and pretty much all across the country
those types of things are not extreme
it's more Washington DC's position that
is Extreme do you sense that maybe some
of that is Shifting I sat down yesterday
with speaker McCarthy at the Capitol and
he was talking about the agenda and sort
of the new Republicans that are here and
there does seem to be a better messaging
at the moment it's partly why I'm here
for three days to talk to all of you
guys because it does seem like
something's a little bit different than
say the Republican of five or ten years
ago yes and and I think I can say I've
played a role in that that was one of my
objectives when I came to Washington was
to change the Republican party you see I
was a regular American never had run for
office wasn't involved in politics at
all but I was very upset with the
Republican party I was a republican
voter but I didn't feel like the
Republicans in Washington reflected our
values and so since I've come to
Washington I've I've never backed down
on the messaging that I've brought the
bills that I've introduced but also
having communication within our
conference sometimes it's been arguments
con you know it's been confrontation at
times it's been explanations and and
really good conversations of here's
where our Republican party needs to move
to this will reflect our voters across
the country and then really be good for
our country overall I supported Kevin
McCarthy in the speaker's race because I
spent a lot of time talking with him
ahead of time about what his goals were
what his objectives were and also I was
I developed a relationship with him and
was really glad that he listened to me
and the things that were important for
my district as well was it funny how
that whole thing was working out in the
strange bed fellows that created because
it was like Trump was supporting him you
were supporting him Gates who obviously
you're in line with on a lot of things
was not supporting him and then
everybody was sort of the media was
loving the fact that you guys weren't
all walking in lockstep which actually I
tend to think is good that people are
thinking for themselves but that it
created all of these odd relationships
that maybe didn't exist before well I
think what it did is it pulled back the
curtain into the Republican conference
and it showed different views that the
media didn't expect and and a lot of
people of course just watching from the
outside didn't expect how hat over half
of the freedom caucus I'm a member of
the freedom caucus over half of the
freedom caucus supported Kevin McCarthy
myself Jim Jordan many others but then
my some of my best friends the people
that I'm always in line with they didn't
they opposed them and then you saw the
debate back and forth sort of the
internal War but like I said it was it
was all on display on cameras on C-Span
and the media was front and center of
course enjoying it well you want to know
why the media really likes to see
Republicans fight with each other but I
have been calling
um basic our internal arguments I call
them the Civil War within the party and
I think it's good I really do this is
what Washington is about it's a it's a
place where we we hammer out debates we
discuss policy and yeah that that means
that we argue sometimes I never think
that's a bad thing what we do have to do
in our conference though is we worked it
out we elected Kevin McCarthy as Speaker
we had our rules package it was the same
literally the same from day one to the
last day only one change to motion to
vacate the chair went from five members
to one member that was the only change
in the rules package but what we had to
do is we had to say all right now that
we've been through this we have to come
together because there's only 222
Republicans takes 218 to pass anything
on the house floor and we we have big
battles ahead we have the budget we've
got the debt ceiling fight
um where we're going to have the ndaa
we've got big things that we have to do
we don't control the Senate and we don't
control the White House so it's it's
some challenges ahead so speaking of
those numbers in the Senate one of the
thing one of the things that you guys
just did pass is this parental rights
and education Bill and as a Floridian I
am well aware of a little transparency
in education obviously uh were you
shocked that not one Democrat signed
this thing I mean all it is about is
basically that you gotta sign up like
back in the day third grade you're going
to the zoo your parents decide something
saying you're going to the zoo I mean it
really it's just about transparency yeah
no they fought Us big time on it when
you're a father as well so I'm sure you
appreciate it and being from Florida you
love your freedom we do love our freedom
no we fought the Democrats on it and so
the the things that they said and the
bill debate um actually presided in the
chair and some of it and then was paying
close attention to that committee they
were accusing Republicans of banning
books book burnings and and not teaching
history they even they even called us
racists they called us all kinds of
names when what we were really saying is
we want parents to have have the rights
to have control over curriculum uh to be
able to talk to their school boards
um of course have control over their
children because they're the parents and
then the second piece there they're also
the taxpayers that fund the schools so I
think their voice should be just as
important and all of us Republicans
agreed uh in spite of not one Democrat
so in AOS C basically calls this thing
fascist which she did on the floor and
then was it Hakeem Jeffries I think said
that they're not going to teach they
don't want the Republicans don't want
the Holocaust to be taught
I'm guessing these guys don't talk to
you on the DL right like you're not
you're not getting a lot of hellos in
the hallways there and being like hey
guys you know it's not true no no and
well here's the mode that they're in so
for people to understand Democrats are
in messaging mode right now so they're
going to fight Republicans in the house
on everything we do because in the house
is the only place that Republicans have
National Power we don't have it in the
Senate we don't have it in the white
house so they're in 2024 presidential
campaign mode so Hakeem Jeffries the the
minority leader in the with the
Democrats he calls us extreme Mega
Republicans every single day AOC calls
us fascists and every other name that
she can think of although I I would say
people should really pay attention to
AOC she's the true fascist you see what
fascism is is it's that um I call it the
Unholy Union of big corporations and big
government and they have completely
aligned together and it hurts the little
people the little people that she claims
to protect and support yeah AOC is
really the fascist herself and isn't it
funny that I mean that's right out of
Rules for Radicals that you're supposed
to accuse the others of what you're
doing that's right and they do it and
they do it well Joe Biden's doing it
right now too if if people have been
paying attention he's tweeted out in the
past like week or so he's he's blaming
Republicans for not wanting to fund
border security to stop fentanyl from
coming in the country which is laughable
because under Joe Biden we've seen
fentanyl increase it's literally doubled
coming in the country and over 300 300
Americans die every single day from
fentanyl poisoning so they they are they
are in messaging mode accusing us of
what they literally do in line about it
what's going on in Georgia these days
because it seems like it's hard to
understand fully what's happening with
Georgia there are Senate seats that kind
of seem like they could go either way
they end up going blue usually obviously
tempted better than uh I think Better
Than People anticipated but it certainly
could have gone the other way and you
have an election denier running against
him even though it's supposed to be only
Republicans that are electionaries it's
sort of a weird state in terms of making
sense of what's going on there what is
that it's probably hard for a lot of
people outside of Georgia to understand
exactly what you explained so Brian Kemp
our governor did something really well
when when all the covid shutdowns
happened Georgia and sorry Florida we
were actually the first state to reopen
um thankfully and and that was something
I taught with Brian Kempa a lot about I
would call him Governor we've got to
reopen we need our schools reopen our
businesses need to be reopened you know
basically begging them thankfully
Governor Kemp listen to all of us that
were asking him for these things we
reopened so our businesses got open
again people went back to work our kids
weren't trapped at home suffering uh
from oh my gosh the list goes on with
that but so so people in Georgia had a
lot of things to be happy with Governor
Kemp about another thing that he did is
he passed constitutional carry Georgia
is a big gun State we have a lot of gun
owners and second amendment supporters
so that was a critical piece of
legislation that he got done and we have
a very strong economy in Georgia so
these are the things that people may
forget about where they get caught up in
watching like the president Trump
Governor Kemp arguments you know those
then those are really more Side Stories
because Trump did want him to keep the
State closed longer than he did in the
beginning yeah that's what and Dr fauci
Burks they were advising president Trump
you can't fault president Trump he was
listening to the people that were
supposed to be the experts and yeah he
was telling everybody to to shut down
Brian Kemp reopened and I think there
was a list of others that reopened so
that shows you like some of the reasons
kind of behind the scenes why people in
Georgia supported him so much and so why
do you think the Senate seats go the
other way well I think it had to do with
candidates
on to do with campaigns another thing
that people may not realize is a
campaign is just like a business and not
all of them do a good job they really
don't there's a lot that goes into a
campaign it's it's messaging is really
important
um there's tv ads and placement radio
ads and placement social media is is
even just as important as TV and radio
maybe even more so it's your ground team
door knocking phone calls I mean it
literally is a mini business and they
always don't they don't always do it
well Herschel Walker's campaign was was
run by Washington DC wasn't run by by
people in Georgia that really understand
uh Republican Georgia voters Mitch
McConnell's views and values are not
accepted in Georgia and that proved to
be true with Kelly lefler's campaign so
when you have uh Mitch team Mitch shirts
going around in my district knocking
doors that's not a good look for your
Republican Senators candidate and and
that's that's just the truth let me ask
you a couple of the other things that
you're sort of in the middle of right
now you were banned on Twitter was was
that your personal account or your
government account just yesterday it was
my government account oh you were banned
yesterday well okay I was talking about
I didn't even know that I was talking
about the original one okay so the
original one was my personal and
campaign account right banned for the
entire year of 2022. it was during my
re-election I couldn't raise money I
couldn't message I couldn't put my ads I
couldn't fight back and defend myself I
only had my congressional account
but I got it back when Elon Musk bought
Twitter thankfully now yesterday my
congressional account got banned and
they said it would be seven days do you
know what what I shared what was it I
shared the same thing that many media
companies Daily Caller and others were
writing articles about it was about the
trans day of Vengeance that was being
planted is planned I did see the tweet I
didn't realize you were banned for it
too I know that Sean Davis whole bunch
of people got got banned or got striped
or locked out of their accounts because
we were warning this looks like a this
looks like a violent extremist uh
terrorist
um and T5 I have entered a resolution
and declare them as domestic terrorists
that's what they are the group
organizing it what is an antifa group
locally and they're they're organizing
this event called
uh trans day of Vengeance yeah just on
the heels of the horrific school
shooting in Nashville
um so all of us were in alarm and I
tweeted about it and got uh banned for
seven days but they've they've reopened
my account this morning right oh so did
they force you to delete the Tweet of
course yeah they forced you to delete
the Tweet but they did at least let you
back yeah but they were whitewashing it
look at this they were trying to
completely take this off of Twitter
which is wrong and and it was this
wasn't any of us attack it was not an
attack on lgbtq not at all this isn't an
attack on anyone's Identity or or sexual
identity we are literally warning about
a violent event that sounds violent
um and it seems connected to the
Nashville shooting right there in the
Supreme Court I'm pretty sure if they
had the Maga day of Vengeance people
would not be that thrilled about that
the DC jail would be full were you able
during the Twitter hearings and there's
some of the are still ongoing and now
there's this Tick Tock situation all
that were you able to find out what
level of coordination actually took your
account out last year I do I do have
some knowledge of that uh John Solomon
has done some really good reporting on
that and then we had the Twitter execs
they came into our oversight hearings as
well I didn't let them talk during my
five we get five minutes so I told them
I said all right you guys you silence me
and stole my freedom of speech uh during
the entire year 2022 during my campaign
I said by the way I won so you did you
weren't that effective but I said so I'm
silencing you for my five minutes and I
proceeded to let them have it and I
called Joel Roth out on on his
disgusting
um uh affection for child porn yeah and
that he it was his duty and his job as
in Twitter to take that off of Twitter
and he did not do it it was really weird
the child porn thing with Twitter
because nobody seemed to care about it
until Elon Musk came over and then said
suddenly everybody cared about elon's
doing more about it than anybody but now
all the articles are that he's not doing
enough of course but nobody cared about
poor but what about the people on the
government side because I kept saying
during the hearings it's not that I have
sympathy for these Twitter people but
they're they're private employees who
are maybe up to no good for sure but
they are also working with government
people and it seems like we still don't
really know who those people are or how
high that goes up that is an extreme
problem so that's in homeland security I
mean we know that that they are the ones
that that run these disinformation
programs in conjunction with the FBI the
CIA and others and so this is a serious
problem it's a weaponization of
government uh basically targeting our
first amendment rights there's a
weaponization of government committee
Jim Jordan is running that committee so
we coordinate on oversight under our
chairman Jamie Comer and we coordinate
on these things but uh do you think you
can do anything on it that's what that's
what everybody always is you know like
okay you have the hearing does anyone
pay the price yeah so I'm a business
owner that's really what I was in a mom
I've got three kids uh before I became a
member of Congress and I know that money
is very powerful so when you don't pay
for something that means that it
discontinues so we've been looking into
things I speak I spoke with Jonathan
Turley last night and he's he had a
great suggestion for us on oversight but
this also goes into our budget and
Appropriations
we give the federal government gives out
grants okay all kinds of Grants and
that's a whole nother topic we could
talk about there's a lot of Grants we
have to cut out but they give out grants
for disinformation so this is basically
tax dollars funding all kinds of groups
outside groups and they spend all their
time
finding things they want to censor then
they would send them to Homeland
Security send them to the FBI and so
forth and then they come in and they
funnel them down and then wipe them off
of not just Twitter which is actually
one of the smaller social media
companies Facebook Instagram on the much
bigger ones let me give you one to look
into because this this will blow your
mind if you didn't hear about do you
know about newsguard have you heard
about News Guard so newsguard is one of
these you know non-profits which is
funded by the government 750 Grand I had
Marissa stripe she's the CEO of prageru
which I'm sure you're familiar with I
had them I had her on my show talking
about how newsguard has been looking
into Prager you and because of that
they're losing contracts with companies
that don't want to work with them
anymore right so then get this that was
a Friday on Monday morning I got an
email from newsguard that they were
looking into me I had never even heard
of them before but by interviewing
someone that they were looking into and
the United States government 750 Grand
to these people so that's a little
there's a great yeah you normally don't
give you homework but but that's a grant
they very likely that grant for that
amount of money or who
weren't probably they have to renew it
each year see that's exactly what we're
going to start looking into but what we
have to do is we have to take that into
the budget and into our Appropriations
process
take a little pencil and it's a racer
and this we're not paying for this we
have to cut spending anyways we should
cut out these programs and so that is
what I'm hoping to do and we have a lot
of heavy discussions right now that are
ongoing with the budget while we're
trying to get you know senile Joe Biden
to actually come talk to us and talk to
Kevin McCarthy and actually start
negotiating some of this well as long as
you went there I mean what's going on
with this President what's going on it
seems to me that everyone in this town
knows something's not right and
everyone's kind of you basically said it
more forwardly than than most at this
point and I have a great respect for
older people I do I think most of us do
but I think um it's it's clear and
obvious to everyone that he's definitely
I mean he's late in his age
um and he and he shows it his physical
and mental and speech capabilities all
show it and and that's wrong it's wrong
of him it's wrong of his family to put
America in this position and it's an
embarrassment but it's also dangerous
for all of us you know the Afghanistan
withdrawal is one of those perfect
examples uh where that was a failed
withdrawal and he's not the only one to
blame there are generals that are to
blame too 13 soldiers dead many more
wounded that no one ever talks about
um uh arming the Taliban 85 billion
dollars worth of equipment and uh
horrific stuff that picture that came
out the other day where they show you
all the tanks and the and the SUVs and
just on the helicopters it's like man we
literally just gave them everything yeah
bag room air base this is the one that
not enough people are talking about we
built Bagram built it used it we should
have never gave it up like okay
withdrawal from Afghanistan but we
should have kept Bagram Air Base because
of its proximity to China and and right
there in the Middle East completely
abandoned that air base and do you know
who's controlling it now
they came in and they came in and
negotiated with the Taliban China Now
controls Bagram Air Base in Afghanistan
this this is these are the failures that
that not enough people know about
um look at the Chinese spy balloon
incident allowed it to travail across
the entire country before they shot it
down you know what that is an example of
that's an example of the type of
information and control that China has
over Joe Biden and his family because of
the corrupt business dealings on the
oversight committee our chairman Jamie
Comer's done a great job leading leading
us into the investigation we've
subpoenaed the Biden family bank records
we have them we literally have you know
they always say follow the money we have
followed it and it is proving that they
were getting payments from China and
let's let's be real does Hunter Biden
have any job qualifications no of course
not 80 grand a month for a consulting
job and something that he had no idea
what he's doing
yes Hallie Hallie Biden she's an
education is she is she qualified to be
in the energy business uh in
International Energy business with China
and U.S no they provided himself I mean
50 years in government now I don't know
that he should be worth millions and
millions of dollars yeah but he's been
here longer than I've been alive
seriously that says it all I'm not young
I'm 48.
uh let's do you got two years on me
let's do uh just a couple other things
um you mentioned to me right before we
started that you're trying to pass the
protect children's innocence Bill
obviously connected to all of the the
gender stuff that everyone is sort of
endlessly talking about it's rather
bizarre it is
um you know I'm a mom so that's the best
part of my life and I just love our kids
and I think childhood is such a precious
and important time and it's a time that
we really have to protect kids and how
they grow and develop and how they feel
about themselves
um and and there's a sexualization
happening in our education system and
then even worse on social media and
tragically we've seen a multi-billion
dollar industry Bloom practically
overnight targeting children so you know
if you've ever heard of Chloe Cole or
maybe you've interviewed her yeah I
haven't but but I know who she is she's
so brave yeah detransitioner and she
she's like a spokesperson for the
community which is actually really big
just not all of them want to come out
it's a difficult thing but hysterectomy
at age 15 had started puberty blacker
blockers at 12 or 13
testosterone you know these are the
kinds of things that are these kids are
doing before they're old enough to vote
buy cigarettes buy alcohol graduate from
high school go to college join the
military big adults get a tattoo even
think about it you got to be 18 to get a
tattoo but they can cut their breasts
off or horrible surgeries genital
surgeries
um it's just wrong and you know it's not
a judgment on them they may be confused
or or developing or have an identity
crisis it's not about that but it's
about this industry for-profit
causing permanent damage to their bodies
before they're even old enough to be
adults do you think you'll get I mean
considering that no Democrats signed on
transparency Bill do you think you'll
get one Democrat to because again I
haven't what I know people will do is
they'll say well she doesn't she's
either a bigot or something towards
trans people which is actually
completely diverse of what you just said
um but but that's probably why a certain
amount of Democrats that maybe aren't
completely off the deep end they'll just
be like I'm not signing on because it's
got marjorie's name on it that and that
could be the case they've done a really
good job creating a character of me that
doesn't exist and they present it to the
public all the time so that that could
be the case but I would I would hope
that they could put uh responsibility
and rational thought uh above politics
and lies in the media because these are
our these are our children and we're
seeing story years later these kids have
serious medical issues and they regret
it and they commit suicide you know they
say this is to prevent suicide they're
committing suicide after they transition
and it's a serious problem but my bill
is really important I have a lot of
support
um it's it's a sort of a flagship bill
for all the states mine was the first
bill introduced in the nation what it
would do is make it a federal law to
stop any so-called gender affirming Care
on anyone under the age of 18. no
puberty blockers no hormone treatments
it stops all of that and it gives these
victims are right to sue if they have
some sort of injury involved if they've
already gone through the process and so
I think it's important and I I really
hope that every Republican will vote for
it I hope that Democrats will come
around and see this is the right thing
to do and we just got to protect kids
and let them grow up philosophically I'm
curious would you prefer that it be done
at the state level or you're obviously
trying to do it at the federal level but
would you prefer I mean obviously Cali's
not going to do it but Georgia might
Florida might you know it sort of
happened it's actually happening in
Florida right now would that be your
preference generally to have everything
be done at the state level I'm a big
state rights person but on this one no
I'll tell you why and I have this
argument with some of my conservative
friends they're saying this is a state
issue Marjorie and I say no it's not
California passed the bill they put it
on Governor newsom's desk and he signed
it making California a trans kids
Sanctuary State Sanctuary state so not
only are they saying that the the
government of California is going to
wrap them in and and make this process
happen for these kids they also take
away parents rights to stop it that is a
state that has crossed the line in my
opinion California is not alone we're
looking at New York we're looking at
Washington we're looking at other states
blue states that are following down the
same track
and going to enable this process even
worse so more children are going to be
victims secondly we do have federal laws
that prevent child abuse and this one to
me falls in the child abuse line and I
think it's important to make it a
federal law if I'm not I might be
mistaken about this but I think I saw
you on Tim Poole talking about sort of
just the division of the states right
now and that the red states are really
well they're working and the blue States
is just not working I've asked several
Congress people about this in the last
couple days I mean what do you make of
that generally and and then what keeps
us United if if that is the direction
that we're going well I I've used the
term National divorce and my words got
twisted around
I used National divorce for a reason
because that's a court process that is a
legal process of of dividing but I did
not want it to be mixed up with civil
war or secession and I'll tell you why
when I talk about a national divorce I
talk about States having more state
rights and I talk about the federal
government being completely shrunk down
more towards where it should have been
and where it started out yeah kind of
like those guys yeah they kind of knew
what they were doing yeah yeah and they
warned us of a lot of the serious
problems that we're seeing today
um I think we maintain a military we've
got to protect our borders
we definitely need need to stay the
United States of America but many
Republicans many conservatives have
gotten so fed up with the left's ideas
um the climate change Lies We I'm sorry
we don't want to give up our gas stoves
we like to be able to buy a gas or
diesel fueled combustion engine vehicle
we don't want to be forced onto electric
I mean we might choose to buy it but we
don't want to be forced we don't want
our children being taught that there's
more than two genders we say there's
only two male and female
um and and so on we could give all the
examples and Republicans you know they
used to say they needed a safe space the
left said they needed a safe space we've
gotten to the place where we're like we
need a safe space yeah and so that's
what I was talking about when I
mentioned National divorce and dividing
up is that just one of those things that
as you're saying it you're like oh I
know what the media is about to do yeah
always they always do it yeah so do you
bother with the CNN and MSNBC and the
rest of them anymore
um they've I don't think msnbc's ever
invited me on they just like to talk
about me every single day
CNN I do talk with them on the hill
um there's a lot of pretty good
reporters on the hill uh I try not to
attack the media because I actually
respect
the press and I really want to see them
I want to see the political bias drop
out of the press and I think the
profession of Journalism is a dying art
and I really want to see it come back
and I want the press and I tell them I
literally tell them this I'm probably
one of the few members of Congress if it
really came down to it that would fight
to the very end to defend their freedom
because I think it's important and it
needs to be preserved and I'm also at
the same time one of the most attacked
people by the Press but I have a faith
in humanity and I really want to see
them do a better job and I would like to
see our press Corps have their freedom
and remove the political bias and just
for the news for the people let me ask
you one more because it's sort of
happening at the moment obviously there
was this horrific shooting in Tennessee
it sounds like the the shooter was
either trans or at least identified in
some way that was not binary or one of
these things
we know that this is going to call for
more pushing of of banning guns I mean
Biden basically is saying it already
obviously you're a big Second Amendment
Advocate
um is there anything I mean what can we
be done here is there anything that can
be done or is this just it's now baked
into the system that these things are
just going to keep happening I have a
unique perspective when I was in 11th
grade it was the first year that then
Senator Joe Biden had gotten the law
passed to make schools gun free school
zones and before that you know the guys
would pull up in their trucks and they
have their their hunting rifles in their
trucks it wasn't uncommon for guns to be
at school but when I was in 11th grade
that law passed schools became gun free
school zones one of the kids at my
school brought three guns to school into
the first period class and took over our
entire school after firing a weapon and
so we spent five hours on lockdown so I
know that fear of being trapped in a
school where there's no good guy with a
gun the only person that has a gun and
he had three was a a very mentally
Disturbed emotionally upset student that
was around my same age and we were all
at Mercy of what he might decide to do
luckily no one died that day so I have
that perspective and I'm and I believe
children are they're our most precious
resource if President Biden is protected
by guns Nancy Pelosi's protected by guns
or capitalists protected by men with
guns I think our kids should be
protected and if this threat is we see
it over and over again if it's going to
keep going well you know what we need to
harden our schools and protect our kids
the same way we protect gold money and
Banks Hollywood celebrities at their big
Banquets and award ceremonies I believe
that's what we should do but I've asked
this question I think we need to finally
take a look at ssris we need to look at
these medications for anxiety and
depression because I mean pretty much
every single one of these shooters is on
or off these meds um I've also wondered
about this particular shooter in
Nashville what medications were they
taking if they were transitioned how
much testosterone yeah because
testosterone creates aggression and if
she's had too much in her body how was
that affected with ssris or whatever
else I think the American people deserve
to know I think I think the coroner's
report should be made public it's time
to have these discussions and then we
need to make decisions there one more on
that what do you think you know they
haven't released the manifesto that
apparently she wrote I'm really 50 50 on
this I believe in transparency but on
the on another side of that if they
release it it almost incentivizes more
people to do it because then it's saying
to them oh I can do something crazy and
then have the whole world read my you
know mind confidence
what do you think about that I
understand that the thought process of
not rewarding that shooter but let's be
real the shooter's dead thank God for
those those officers that went in and
which that was unbelievable I mean
unbelievable
um and so I'm I I believe in the truth
being told and we've seen manifestos in
the past I think this one should be
released it should be part of studying
what's wrong and exposing
um there also could be a network of
people that's something that is being
investigated actually by law enforcement
because of this planned uh um uh trans
day of Vengeance here in Washington
organized by an antifa group and there
were talks or there have been talks of a
group that raise money for firearms
training to defend trans rights these
are all discussions and maybe that
Manifesto has information about this
again it's um it could be a group of
people that were organized and
supposedly this group called for Action
in Nashville I don't know this is or
things that are floating around and up
to I would hope the Department of
Justice would take it serious the same
way they're targeting January 6 uh
people that walked in the Capitol they
should be taking this serious and so I
do think it should come out all right
one more on a slightly less serious note
do you have access to the Jewish space
laser
I don't but I funded them I voted to
fund them I I support Israel I never sat
in the things
no it's been a pleasure chatting with
you and I hope we can do it again yeah
let's do it again thank you so much if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell